i have the distinct honor and pleasure
today to introduce you guys and to talk
to somebody i've looked up to
for a really long time his name is chris
ashworth as part of our
double double feature today part one of
live stream today is with
chris ashworth now i going to jump into
my deck here
when i was looking for pictures of chris
and you notice like there's a fuzzy
out-of-focus image here like what is
going on
for me to find an image of chris it was
like searching for bigfoot
lots of images came on the internet but
i could not find anything of him
and when he finally submitted a picture
it was like this thing that was kind of
very mysterious so he's a man of mystery
so
i started thinking like this is in
search of the legendary
chris ashworth also known as swiss
grit and then this image comes up and
this most definitely is not chris cause
this is an american actor
who plays the russian on hbo's the wire
so we got to find some clues you guys we
got to go on instagram to find out who
chris is and
again no pictures of chris just
typography
beautiful design but you guys should
definitely go check him out right now
at ashworth chris check him out check
out his work
i've noticed since i was following him
his following has grown
pretty fast now he's up to 31 000
followers so check out his work
for daily inspiration some really cool
stuff so i want to dive a little deeper
even on wikipedia
there's not a lot of information on
chris this tells me something about him
but we'll get into that in a little bit
later
so he went to the york college of arts
and technology and he started a design
studio called
orange designing highly reproducible
nightclub flyers
we'll get into that he's also the former
art director of raygun magazine
and here are some of the beautiful
layouts check this out
and now you know why i look up to him
he's a topographer so you also did
magazines in conjunction with other
designers but here are some examples
really beautiful stuff look at these
layouts
now some of you young guns out there
looking at this like oh that's like
what texture pack is he using what kind
of filters and
we'll find out a little bit more about
his process in a little bit and he also
designed this book with michael stipe
two times intro
and then look at these layouts
beautiful stuff and we'll ask him a
little bit later why he
likes the term swiss great i think
that's a term he made up
and these are layouts from his instagram
account and i just
love seeing the very tactile things in
there with the tape the duct tape and
this lettering that's applied on top
you're looking at that it's like did he
do that photoshop
he did not do it in photoshop
and i can see a pattern here with
fascination of
distress typography layering materials
tape
paper rub down lettering
and then i assume maybe this is a found
typography part of his inspirational
files maybe maybe not and then he'll do
typesets like this
and then you go onto his website and
again it's very hard to find information
about chris so you guys going to be in a
treat because
i don't know how many interviews he does
but we're going to try to get as much
information from chris in a little bit
so this is the website and it's at c
ashworth.com beautiful minimalist
layout somewhat difficult to navigate i
must admit
but beautiful stuff so if you guys want
to see like how designers work
pre-computer post computer whatever
there's some amazing things on here
and currently he's the creative director
modern life and devices creative studio
at microsoft and some other job titles
he's had
the brand creative director at nokia
creative director at getty images
owner um typo there and founder of still
media art director of ray gun publishing
which we talked about
owner of substance senior designer at
mtv europe
and designer is that egg eg.g
okay chris everybody help me welcome
chris to the show guys
there he is i was thinking maybe you're
in the witness protection plan
yeah i'm uh i don't know why
yeah i like i like looking at the work
right i like yeah it's not about me
uh-huh so do you also have an opinion
about people who show much
too much of themselves uh no i don't
have a problem with it i
i guess i'm like you know i grew up on
new order yeah
people um man a mystery
didn't put on the sleeve for i don't
know how many years
they were you know pink floyd all that
stuff so i'm like
i'm more interested in the the creatives
and the i don't know the
person behind it although it is
interesting like some of my heroes when
i
had the chance to meet them or or read
about them
um it's good putting a kind of face to
the
the name right yes so we will have to
then screen capture you from this just
to get an image
okay so fantastic so uh i i thought you
were in the uk but then i was
looking you up on linkedin i realize now
you're in are you in seattle washington
i am yeah and how long have you been and
how long have you lived in the united
states and
and are you planning to stay here for a
long time or it's just i am
you are okay i've got a pair of twins
now so um
they keep me they keep me busy yeah i've
been here on and off since uh
2000 i've lived in america four times my
wife
if if we relocate one more time she's
she's just
it's just going to tip her over the ass
she's done with you yeah okay
and do you like being in america what
are the cultural differences that you
see
uh in america and in uk or
london or whoa
uh that's a big question man um i know
some like practical differences you
don't have pubs here which is a major
problem
okay you know fish and chips yes uh
leopards pie all that kind of stuff
custard i have to get it all in pork
um yeah cultural differences um
i i think you know i'll just hit one so
i think
you know where i'm from we're used to
kind of speaking our mind a little bit
and um
i guess kind of saying how we think and
not not really expecting anyone to sort
of take offense by but just just um
you know say what's on your mind and
have a good dialogue about it i think
some of the
time i've um found over here you know
you have to kind of be a little bit more
guarded with your
kind of opinions and how you um
express yourself i guess but anyway
you know i wasn't i was recently
at an event in manchester and they were
talking about the american attitude
versus the british attitude
and there's a sense of like i don't know
if it's cynicism
sarcasm or self-deprecating but there's
just
a little darkness to it and i totally
agree with you in terms of
certain countries and cultures are very
direct in how they feel and they think
while american and canadians are a
little bit more kind of
careful with how they want things and
you can get in trouble if you say
say things too clearly and too directly
right well yeah i have a brit friend
here at microsoft in our studio and
we uh when we get at it we're like we're
like the gallagher brothers or something
in a meeting
and everyone else is like you can hear a
pin drop that they're like you know
they think we're never going to talk to
each other again right and then
half an hour late we're having a coffee
so um
i don't know we just you know you just
kind of fight your corner and if you
believe in summit you gotta be so
passionate about it right mm-hmm
now earlier i was mentioning that you're
a man that's kind of hard to find
and that tells me something usually
usually tells me that you're so busy
with work and professional life
you don't have time to update things and
i suspect that's true now you're
you're the creative director there at
microsoft how did you
come about to work there and what's it
like uh i mean
okay let me just be careful about how i
phrase this question like what drew you
to microsoft and why are you there
um so yeah that's the kind of a
hopefully an interesting story so um
when i was at getty images
um they had two offices okay one in
london
one in fremont in seattle which was
their headquarters
um so i ran those two studios creative
studios
um and i hired this guy um out of um
uh what do you call it like um oh
like uh pronter print like a like a copy
design company he just went out of
college and he went into this
this place so i basically i hired him as
a contractor in my studio
um and he he used uh he used
he used to be he was an amazing designer
and typographer very kind of green
but um he used to come in like 11
o'clock
and we'd have these meetings at 9 9 30
and uh this guy would be on the hook to
um
to be part of this meeting or share some
files or something
and he just basically completely missed
the meeting because he'd been out the
night before
so eventually i had to have this chat
with him i'm like sorry mate you know
this is great you're great but it's not
gonna work out unless you
kind of get in here on time so anyway we
party company
then um i went back to the uk um
and changed my job i ended up at nokia
did that for two years and whilst i was
doing that i was all
always trying to get back to america i
wasn't really enjoying it back in uh in
london
so um this guy who i just described the
one i had to let go
um he he sent me an email one day just
out of the blue he said i don't know
whether you're interested but there's
this creative director job going at
microsoft in seattle
um so he'd actually got a job at
microsoft
in those subsequent couple of years um
sorted himself out a bit got a bit more
organized
and um yeah he took me about this job
and the rest is kind of history so
um and he he turned he's a great guy
he's a great designer
i've learned actually learned a lot from
him um so yeah kind of a
interesting story of like compassion
um with one that i i kind of gave a
break to in design way back
that is really cool so that tells me a
lot about how you manage
people because somebody that you said
you know basically
you let him go right yeah yeah
and the way that you did it the person
that you were when he moved on in his
life in his career he thought about you
and
maybe you were the that wake-up call
that he needed in his life
so that then he could focus up and then
he gets his job and he then he
recommends you for the job
that's cool yeah exactly again i i think
he he um
he was a quick learner and i think he
got excited about
typography and design through um not
just working with me but there was one
one of my good friends mark franklin
um he kind of brought him along a lot so
yeah i think it kind of it dawned on him
that maybe
maybe you should give a bit more of a go
i think and um
maybe get yeah his uh these late nights
in check a little bit at least during
the week
right okay so one of the reasons why i
mentioned at the beginning of the show
that i looked up to you before i even
knew who you were was mostly through
this magazine that was
very influential for a lot of us
designers and it's ray gun
and i think when it popped onto the kind
of scene
it was done by david carson who was like
just at that time
the monster of the design world every
mag
everything you touched it's like there's
david carson's all over it
so here's my first question for you why
were you brought into art direct ray gun
and then i found out through wikipedia i
think you designed 15 issues so why only
15 issues
all right so the first one was why
why did i work on reagan yeah why were
you brought on to do
to do ray gun after carson yes so
so let's just rewind a little bit so
yeah when i was at college in
89 90 um just as i was kind of
leaving college you know i started
seeing surf a beach culture magazine
a lot of stuff rudy van der lans was
doing emigrate
and then carson started doing reagan and
i i had this like really rigorous um
couple of years
being taught by a swiss a swiss um
typographer um he was my lecturer
at york college and when i'd so i i had
the whole grid
the whole grid system and clear space
all that sort of stuff
grilled into me and then i started to
get exposed to
you know what carson was doing a lot of
the um west coast american designers
and um it just became a sort of you know
where i am today with my work is
is somewhat of a fusion of those two
things
um in a way so he was one of my heroes
when i was starting out
and so when i when i did some of my own
work in my own studios
um for no money but just you know the
hell of
doing creative work um i started to get
a little bit of a name for myself
and marvin jarrett who is you know
raygun
bikini magazine heart magazine stick
magazine
all those cool kind of magazines from um
the 90s
he came to london he wanted to
publish a magazine in london and he did
he got he basically set a partnership
with mtv
um so the two of them wanted to do a
music magazine
and marvin reached out to one of my
great friends louis blackwell
yep he went down a lot of books he did
the carson
and the print book he was the editor on
that um he worked at creative review
magazine so
basically um lewis gave my name to
marvin
and then marvin got in touch with me and
me and my my friend neil fletcher who we
worked on our substance design studio
together the two of us
pitched um design ideas cover ideas
spread ideas
for this soon-to-be music magazine
coming out of the uk
and we won the pitch um the magazine
lasted you know six issues before
um it was sold to someone else when we
quit
and at that time i was already starting
to do this raygun
culture book for marvin um which is a
hardback book that was published by
booze klibben um in 96. so as i was
doing that
marvin asked me if i wanted to come to
la and do ray
uh take over from the art director who
was there at the time
um and so yeah i mean i couldn't i
couldn't pass up that chance so uh
so then to your other question yeah i
did i did 15 issues
um jan 97 to june 98
and again same kind of story marvin um
decided he wanted to sell the
the title um to to someone else and it
just felt like the right
time to um go back to england
i see so i i think part of the story
there is
you moved out to santa monica right
because i think i read in your instagram
post
from yeah i actually lived on bundy
drive um
bunda yeah we know exactly where that is
uh-huh
um so yeah i lived there and then the
office was on um
santa monica boulevard but the um kind
of the
santa monica end of that yeah and is
that where reagan was being designed or
headquarters or that's just where you
set up office
no it was it was there for um for quite
a long time
yeah it was there when i got there okay
so what did you do
right after that uh after they decide
they're going to sell the
title to somebody else what was your
next thing um move back to london
and um set up my own studio again which
sounds very grand but it was just
me in an attic room on um
denmark street which is a kind of
slightly infamous street where
they sell um a lot of music equipment
and i used to see all sorts of uh sort
of famous
uh musicians buying equipment on that
street they call it tim pan alley i
think
i saw liam and no buying some guitars
there once
i did that for like a year and then i'm
like you know i want to do something
else
i don't want to work for my just me and
myself
i want to do something else so lewis
then i mentioned him earlier he rang me
that i'm i'm i just got this gig at
getty images
uh running their creative studios
doing all the kind of promo marketing
and you fancy doing that
like running a team of like 15 designers
and writers and i'm like
louis you know you're insane i've like
i've never i've never managed anyone in
my life
so um he took a punt on me and
i i started doing that and i never
looked back um
i i kind of love i love what i did
before
for 10 years on my own kind of thing or
with one other person but
working with the people is white
yeah okay you it's ironic that you're at
microsoft right now and
you are admitted like i don't love
technology i like making designing
things so
i saw this thing that you put out a
couple days ago on instagram and you the
headline was
paper doesn't crash so i would love for
you to talk
a little bit about your relationship or
affection foreign
man it will never let you down right
so can you tell us about a little bit
about your process how you work and then
maybe tie that into the whole idea of
swiss grit and what that means
yeah so i mean i've always made things
with my hands
um i i think the defining moment for me
was
um i i when i was at college like i said
i had this
i had this huge background in just
really rigorous kind of swiss graphic
design
and i got i took the train one day from
southport to manchester and i
i bumped into this exhibition i didn't
know it was going on
it was called sublime um at the corner
house
and it basically had a celebration of
graphic designers who were from
manchester who worked in the record
industry
there was malcolm garrett peter savile
mark farrow
on 8vo johnson panas
so i i walked into this exhibition um
and i walked into a room it was just
white big room high ceiling white walls
wood floor
and in the middle was a glass case um
and on the glass case was different
layers
of visual elements type
hand-drawn type done on tracing paper
stuck down on the glass with sellotape
a kind of some image guitar images some
kind of bars that were drawn out with
kind of uh felt it pens and um
basically all these different kind of
graphic elements on different layers of
glass
and i what i realized i was looking at
was essentially the artwork for um apos
the guitar and other machines leave
um which is designed by down by
fio so
that had a i was like what you can
actually
though it doesn't have to look perfect
and i i kind of i was something about
the tactile nature of it and the
the fact that it was all um there before
my eyes
um in terms of the artwork and so ever
since that moment i've been really
interested in like
things that feel human and natural
and kind of um have some personality to
them
you know things done on the computer
just look like everyone else's thing is
done on a computer to me
um so i'm kind of fascinated by um
you know everywhere i go everywhere i
walk i've got dogs when i walk the dogs
i'm always finding bits to type and
stuff
and it gives me inspiration for my work
um so i i guess it's what i
see and what i feel um is is to me what
i try and make and
and and almost recreate sometimes
so the process that i go through when i
like i'm working on something for um
a company in wales right now and uh i
i set the type uh in this instance i set
it on screen and then i
i just basically print out a hundred
copies of it
and start i put some in the washing
machine last night
um i i just get you know tape
it up um we're going up to we have a
little place in the mountains um it's
got six foot of snow
so tonight when i get there i'm taping
all these sheets of paper to the floor
of my carriage
um so over the next three days we're
gonna drive
in and out over them um rip them up
get them covered in snow and dirt and
grit and everything
then i'll dry them out with a hair dryer
and see what i've got
um so yeah it's just i just wow i love
that
so for a lot of our young listeners who
are tuning in who are
really much pretty much just grew up
using digital tools this is going to
sound
very foreign to them i love that you
described that that because i was like i
wonder how much chris is involved in
scratching and damaging the type because
i can tell it's
it's analog and in the way that you do
it and you're you're actually doing it
the hardest way possible but then you
get this really richness to the to the
work itself
it's funny i was doing this thing last
night and um you can't buy sellotape in
america that's another problem i've got
with america
so i have to import it roles of
sellotape
um so i was doing some type last night
and because i do it so
fast i can't be bothered to use scissors
so i just cut it with
my teeth i've taken all the layer of
skin off my lips
because when you it's really sticky this
stuff so when you bite it
it if it gets stuck to your lip you just
pull your lips
i'm like i thought i wasn't going to be
able to do the interview today i'm like
i've got no skin on me
so cello tape is that like clear tape is
that what we're talking about
yeah it's like clear tape but it's
actually got this sort of
cigarettey kind of yellowy danny feel to
it
so um if you put some of that down and
leave it it gets really good
it just gets more yellow yes
so that probably means it has some kind
of acid to it that it's right
it's reacting to paper and so over time
the artwork keeps growing and changing
and evolving that's what you're looking
for right something that's organic and
alive
i mean like 3m i guess have perfected it
over time so it's just
always clear right but i like the always
yellow
that means that probably aside from
ripping the skin off your lips a little
bit
you're probably leaving some kind of
chemical on your lips
yes if i pass out during this
yes so i want to take a look back at
some of your work on uh
from my slide here from instagram now
that you guys understand the context
you'll
have a greater appreciation for what's
going on here so
i i'm assuming that's a real piece of
duct tape and
this is rub down lettering like letter
set stuff right
yeah yeah tightly and now you can see
like where this is coming from so
damaged pieces of paper so chris is
saying he'll print out a hundred copies
after he's typeset it
he'll cut it apart now some of this
doesn't have the tape
so is this glue stick now yeah i just
use like a
good old-fashioned print stick mm-hmm
beautiful stuff and you spray him out a
lot but that's just like
um yeah it's not good for the for
anything
it gets everywhere it doesn't stay on
yeah yeah i've ruined a few carpets
without stuff
yeah okay so maybe this is a time i i'm
not sure
people who are tuning in live you guys
want to get your questions in on
on youtube go ahead and drop in the
questions is it jonah that's going to be
monitoring comments today jonah is that
it sure
is okay is there any good questions yet
or do i just keep talking to chris yep
uh i'm gonna put out a post saying give
us some questions
oh okay so we're still waiting for some
people to comment all right i see
lots of things usually it takes them a
while to warm up some admiration from
you
for the work now i know that in the
current pantheon of design or
part of the design guys right now is
like clean modern very simple
so this is going to be a shock to your
system this morning you guys but this is
the stuff that i
it when i came of age in terms of being
a graphic designer
this is stuff i saw and loved now i
didn't go to the extent of like washing
my typography
it's kind of interesting you wash it to
get it dirty so it erodes things
right so it's and you're driving over
things with your car and you're always
thinking about
how can i actually expose it to elements
in a way that i see in the real world
because that's really what's happening
it's not a filter it's not a
displacement map it's not chemicals it's
just letting it do its
thing over time yeah it's another good
one i
am i i stuck some type to the bottom of
my kids shoes
so um they you know they went to school
and
jumped around and all the rest of it and
so it got actually it's really nice when
it came back
wow did they know that it was on the
bottom of their shoe
no i did it when they're in bed
right genius okay so i have another
question here
we have a mutual friend in common in
robert house and many years ago i worked
with him
on several music videos and i believe if
if i remember correctly there was some
overlap between you and robert right
yeah i mean it was literally like he did
i think issue um
let me get this right um
oh sorry uh i think he yeah he did 42
and then i did 43.
did he do 42 then you did 43 and then he
was gone or you guys went back and forth
or how did that work
oh yeah he was yeah he went to mars he
went
to mass media he's i think he did some
nine inch nail stuff straight away so
he didn't do too badly
you guys get to work on some really cool
projects i'm very jealous
okay so here's another question for you
in terms of like somebody
who's getting out or okay let me
rephrase this
i look at you and you have a very
interesting career and you know you're
you're hanging around with all these
legendary designers
now the climate and atmosphere is quite
different we're not concentrated in
certain areas or if you live in the
middle of nowhere
how does somebody that's kind of
relatively new to the design field
who wants to who aspires to kind of have
the the career that you've had
do you have any advice on how how they
can get started what they can do
yeah i mean i i literally had
i mean not like i have anything now but
i didn't know i had nothing
when i started um and it was
you know we didn't have you know we
didn't obviously didn't have the
internet or social media so
um all i used to do was
do what i felt was right and do what i
was passionate about
do things that actually i wanted to do
like my dad wanted me to get this job in
this advertising
agency when i left college they offered
me i didn't work placement they offered
me a job
and it would have been you know it would
have been so easy to go and do it
but i would have been bored brought to
tears they were declining beer cans
so i want i did this thing i started
with my two mates from college
and we literally made no money for three
years
um but we did what we wanted to do and i
used to we used to
send our work into magazines that was
the only way you could get exposure
because you know like i said it wasn't
the internet and and and so just
through doing that and being passionate
about it and believing it
i know it sounds corny but it's true you
believe in it's like when you're in a
band
you know you start with nothing if
you've got some ideas and some belief
then you can go a long way
so i i just i get a lot of people on
instagram that are asking
ask me similar things and like now i
just try and encourage them to
to kind of pursue what what
what excites them and what they're
passionate about
on the sidelines um
yeah it's a hard one to answer that
well now that you bring up instagram and
people asking you questions on instagram
uh because i get asked the same
questions over and over again
let's clear the air so that you don't
have to answer it ever again what are
some of the most
repetitive questions that you get on
instagram so that you can just stay here
and you can just say just go watch this
video so i don't have to say it again
oh no i don't yeah no i i don't have a
yeah i don't have a problem with that
because i actually you know
i'm i'm not a huge fan of social media
it's the irony
like i've never been on facebook or
anything but instagram to me is
again it's gonna probably sound corny
but it's it's helped me get in touch
with a so many people that i've
lost touch with um since i've i've kind
of been doing more of this kind of
corporate stuff
and it's got me back into the thing that
i'm most passionate about
um in terms of my career just just
personal kind of typography and
self-expression so
it's given me a platform i think and
when i get these comments and questions
from people
um i just try and give a little back and
try and give some of them
them some pointers or them some
encouragement or
so for me it's been nothing but a good
thing really
okay well fantastic well i'm gonna ask
you one of those questions that you may
get all the time so here we go
this is coming from um abhishek bahara
and he's like
what is the trick to overlap type
without overdoing it
uh
overlap type yeah um
i'm not sure exactly what that means but
um i mean i
i just use a lot of tape and the more
you pull up
the more you pull off you know if you
basically
if you print something out multiple
times and pull it up multiple times
and then basically put the tape each
time
over the top of one another then the
amount of
the amount of pieces you put down
obviously affects the the legibility and
the kind of density of it
um yeah i mean that's just that
that's just kind of a simple way of
doing it i guess i think the question
he's asking is
when when designers are starting out
they're a little nervous about where to
put stuff and so even the idea of
overlapping and layering the way
that you do things they don't that are
not sure like how do i not
overwork it not necessarily from a
technical point of view but
when you know that it's too layered and
you've lost all
it's gone off the deep end maybe that
was this question
i mean i guess for me it's
it's one of these interesting areas
where we're talking about a technique
and i think to me it has to be in
in um in relation to an idea
so if the idea or the thing you're
trying to
convey is something that is you know
it's hard to describe or if um
it is is quite dark or
if the subject matter is is of that kind
of
nature then you know you take it to the
point that it's like
as close to utter eligibility maybe
whereas if you're trying to create
something that's a a different sentiment
and has a
a different kind of message to it then
you would you would do it more
more cleanly right i think that's the
thing for me
it's all well and good um
creating techniques but like i say like
i'd like to think a lot of what i do
is is um in in relation to like i'm
trying to communicate a certain sort of
tone
or um an idea um and that's
you know that's born out of the words
that i'm kind of messing with
yeah since you're making essentially
pieces of artwork in the process of
design where it's kind of crossing over
between design and art
yeah how are you archiving all this
stuff because if it's a digital file it
sits on a drive in the cloud
are do you have flat files full of pages
and layouts
you should uh we should have my wife on
at this point so
is literally full of cardboard boxes um
so we've moved house i think 17 times
since we've been married oh my goodness
i take these boxes and she's like you
haven't opened those
since the last time we moved um and i
said i've been carting them around for
for i know 25 years or something so
that's why like i'm saying this
instagram thing is allowing me to kind
of
crack open some of the boxes and look
look back through my work and it's kind
of inspired me to
to do new stuff um but yeah i literally
i have boxes and boxes of paper yeah i'm
a bit of a hoarder so yeah
well i've noticed that on instagram you
pretty you seem to have a pretty
consistent lighting and camera setup
is that something that you set up in the
studio where you you pull out a piece of
artwork you photograph it and then post
it onto instagram
yeah so that mate is not so what that is
is a a stool with a ball
and a white sheet of paper stuck to it
yes and then
every weekend i'll choose a few things i
want to
i want to share that week yeah and and
then i basically
just keep going into this room whenever
i've got a moment i do a photo
where um i try and catch the light at
the right
the right time of day but it's either
too blue too
yellow right you know i literally like i
said i'm a technophobe so all i know is
to like
put the thing in front of the window and
click
so it you know it has a certain
consistency to it i guess but it um
i'd like to try and make it a little bit
easier to capture
well you sure fooled me i thought you
had this really great like studio set up
like this is how
a professional does it right it's all
set up on a copy stand and lights and
it's consistent
so when you say click are you shooting
on film are you shooting on your iphone
are you shooting at a digital camera
with an iphone yeah
really yeah wow okay
well so this this is another i guess
proving the point here in that
it's really not the tools it's really
what you know right so you're sitting
there
you kind of know i want to create the
certain soft shadows and the color
temperature you're aware of all these
things
that's fantastic i love that and yeah i
just want to say this not that you would
ever do this but if you ever want to get
rid of some boxes
i know where to send them to all right
just let you know
so i want i'm doing it as a public
service announcement to you and your
wife i'm going to keep the marriage
together
so if you never need to get rid of some
boxes send them our way now i'll tell
you
uh i have boxes of reagan magazine some
from carson some from you and i still
have them around here somewhere
but i started to question myself like
what am i doing with this if i don't
display this somewhere
it's just in a box and it's not being
loved and appreciated is it giving
me joy well i don't know i'm a hoarder
too so i'm like
then what i did was because i have so
many boxes i got rid of the innards and
i just kept the cover so it's like okay
it's a little bit more reasonable now
but not sure i can speak to you anymore
now
pretend i didn't say that
yes okay yeah as you move you start to
feel the weight of your collection but
i'm glad that you're not throwing them
away because they need to be in a
gallery somewhere where we can
appreciate or at least scan in on the
internet so we can
i don't know yeah it's so hard to find a
couple of things on that so i am
my dream is like a book in 2020 because
it'd be 30 years of um
of me messing around with time mm-hmm
i'm kind of got that in the works
um the um if i can pull that off then i
would i would definitely
like to do some kind of like some
openings
um with um some of this actual work on
display
just back to the start you showed my
website so that's a bit of a running
joke because i'm
i'm determined to put this book out
before my website
actually goes live so that's thing that
you were looking at it's just like a
it's not even a beta it's just us trying
to see what things look like so
it's not actually supposed to be live
yet oh
i'm basically on this like the analog is
going to beat the digital
yeah that thing that's not like you were
saying like it's hard to navigate and
like that's because it doesn't
work you're like uh dummy because it's
not supposed to be out there yet thanks
i was thinking you know what i was
thinking i thought this was an art
statement in itself it was a giant
middle finger because almost everything
i clicked on didn't work and
broken links and one time i think i
clicked on something and i tell the
directory i'm like am i supposed to see
this
it's there okay but i encourage you i
encourage you i'll be the first person
to
to fund the kickstarter project where
you're going to publish the book because
i'm an old school guy i want it in my
hands i want to see it high-res and it's
full printed glory
i think um not i think i know hbo did
the same
i bought the book it's gorgeous and i
got to see all the behind the scenes
stuff
the layering and this is another point
of intersection between you and i and
that
you saw that design yeah and simon
johnson
was one of the principals at hvo and
he's my type professor from art center
so we have that kind of
shared dna yeah brilliant yeah yeah i
met him in l.a
you did yeah great guy so yeah one of
the founders of hbo
legend living legend yes
and i've been trying to get my my former
professor to come on the show i actually
interned for him too but he's like
uh oh yeah i'm camera shy i'm not gonna
come on the show i'm like oh shoot
but i'm glad you did i was fortunate to
work with mark
holt um at nokia he was like a
contractor there
helping with some creative and design
when i turned up so
i have this photo of him cutting this
piece of paper with a scalpel
um and it's like one of my all-time best
photos like having him
in a design movement yes
now i know you said before that uh you
you don't really
you want it to be about the work but i
think the world would appreciate a
little bit more of you
in the work so that we can see you and
just kind of know the man behind the
machine
if you will so i want to encourage you
to do that but i understand
you got to do what you got to do is
there another question uh jonah because
we don't have that much more time with
chris because
he's a busy man he's got to go to a
meeting yes there is yes so that's a
good question
sanders asks is there such thing as
making a mistake in your type and
creative work
it looks deliberate yet random oh yeah
totally mistakes are the best best
things
oh my some of my favorite work that i've
done is
literally there's a mistake in there um
let me see if i can find an example so
um yeah i mean well i know it's a
mistake but like i do all these things i
used to do a lot of stuff that was like
much more by chance so um
leave it where it landed i i think was
kind of this thing that we used to do
where
you would um on the covers of reagan
as an example we would now you kind of
have multiple
one those open with different kind of
you've got your type on one and
maybe you've got your image and your
masted on one um you're trying to set
the type on one and
you've got your bar so we would compose
the
the cover with all the elements and then
the last thing you'd put
on invariably would be the barcode so
you would uh
you just basically copy paste it in um
and we had this sort of joke thing where
you just leave it where it landed
um dane's addiction cover it landed on
the drummer's head
so um i just left it
and then after the mag came out
we uh marvin walked into my my design
room one day and he's like we got a
problem mate
um i just got a phone call from the uh
you know the manager of jane's addiction
and the drummer is pissed
um so he's you know he's seen the cover
on the newsstand and like
so we had to make him this massive
poster of the cover without obviously
the barcode
um and frame it right nicely frame it
and
and get it sent over to his house as a
sort of um
as an apology but uh so yeah
it kind of backfired a bit of that one
i always remember this quote from emmel
ruder um
fortuitous um and unexpected results
are um
uh fortuitous and unexpected results are
foreign from the nature of typography i
think it's similar
um and he was like one of my heroes when
i was growing
up at college um and i kind of always
it was always funny like i liked so much
of what he talked about but then
and that quote stuck in my mind as
something that actually i
kind of rallied against a little bit um
because i saw
the unexpected stuff though so
it catches your eye so if i'm if i'm
interpreting that quote does that quote
mean that
in the in the design and deliberate
practice of typography that there's not
that much chance for randomness and then
you
introduce randomness back into it you're
going to be thoughtfully
created and corrected
what what how should i justify it what
typeface and
what's the weight all these things and
so okay so everybody needs to understand
this so
so what chris was talking about before
was introducing deliberately
randomness to the design so a lot of
it's controlled and i think that's where
it gets structure from
and then copying and pasting and
wherever it lands on the screen boom
we're just going to go with it we like
it we don't like it we don't care we're
moving on
and the one time it came back to bite
you in the butt was genuine addiction
but that's fine right
nobody was physical yeah yeah but we
would create like on
like um feature layouts and magazine
stuff
um we would we would put boxes on the
layouts
that didn't have anything in them and
you couldn't see them but they were
there
and when you dropped in elements over
the top they would rag
the elements in different ways so they
would kind of
just knock them out of shape or knock
them out a line
and it's all that kind of stuff that um
i i think we've we always found kind of
just fascinating
i i have another question for you uh to
me the 90s was this
decade of uh exploration and topography
people were just doing so many crazy
cool things
now that we're 20 plus years removed
from it
do you think some of that spirit is gone
and how do you feel about it
oh man um
yeah i think about that a lot i'm i'm
just i never
come to any conclusion it
it's i remember when i when i was
starting out
um you could count the amount of
designers you knew
on basically two hands in terms of not
knowing
personally no i mean know their work um
who were practicing and now like
i know everyone's a designer but that's
not a bad
thing um i don't know they just
doesn't seem to be a movement right now
right it hasn't been for a while
i don't know whether everything's been
tried and there's nothing
i'd like to think there was plenty of
things out there that haven't been
haven't been kind of unearthed yet right
um like i made this point this morning
on my post i think about
you know lecture set started off um in
the 50s 60s 70s 80s as a
basically a cheap communication tool
that's literally what it was because
there weren't any computers
um you could make your own sign um and
get your message out there and i think
craft
handcrafted things have kind of come
full circle right
um people are valuing those things much
more and just in terms of product design
as well and
and things that are made by people
personal not robots all that kind of
stuff so
i think there's for me there's a
movement in that kind of crafted space
that's that's happening um it will be
lovely to see more of that i think in
our world in our graphic design world to
me
um um i i would you know i would like to
see a lot more of that
because i think that's what what draws
you in right it's so
if if if there's a feeling behind the
work
it it it's it's it's like how you
connect with people right
um that that there's that kind of
tactility and that kind of personality
to it
that i think in a way is quite
disruptive now because we're also used
to seeing things that are so perfect and
computer generated
yeah i think people are yearning for
that hand done stuff now and i can see
that it's the pendulum is swinging back
to
yeah where's the human in the work
yeah exactly um you mentioned letraset
are they still manufacturing letter set
sheets or do you have the world's
largest collection
yeah no and yes okay they're not um
i did a bit of uh i don't know i did a
bit of research last night i think um
windsor and newton who like they make
paintbrushes
um they bought them um so they own that
company now but i
i don't think they're putting out i'm
pretty sure they're not putting out any
electricity
um but yeah i went to this art supply
shop in uh
just down from microsoft before
christmas
um so i went in there someone told me
about it i went in there and it was like
a business to business
store and there was no one in there
apart from a dog
it was saturn reception so i went in and
i'm looking around and it's like you
know there's dust on everything and blah
blah blah
and then this lady came out she's like
you know can i help you
so i'm like yeah i'm like um i noticed
you had this lecture set
pad like a plain paper
um you don't have to have any electro
set sheets do you
and she goes funny you should mention
that like come down here so we went like
down this corridor
into this storage room and she had like
i mean i she had like 20 000 sheets
oh my god jeez the motherland and like
they were literally they cut they
couldn't be bothered to throw them out
in the skip
so they were just in this storage room
gathering dust i'm like i'm just totally
speechless right
so i'm like how much do you want for
them because i knew she's going to throw
them out
so um she get you know she came back she
asked the boss and he's like 500
so i rang my wife and um that was my
christmas present so
um 20 000 sheets i i still can't believe
it
wow they're in my room full of cardboard
boxes
this is fantastic because what you're
doing in the tools that you're using is
very ephemeral it's gonna be all gone
and now you must like these are my
children right now i need to package
them up very carefully because
they do dry out right and they don't
work as well like the auric golf finger
with the gold thing right yeah i'm like
stop piling lecture set
[Laughter]
this is fantastic uh chris i know you
have to run i want to ask you one more
question and if it's too long to answer
just give me the shortest version of
this
how does all this experimentation and
analog work and
analog work and distress type inform the
work that you do today
uh microsoft well yes
um
it doesn't directly inform it because
we're doing a different kind of work i
think
um but what i would say is it it
it fuels me so
when i've when i've put the twins to bed
and i i get my my work my my type out
and start making things
it kind of lights me up it kind of gives
me this kind of um
it's like kryptonite so when i don't
come into work i'm so
i'm kind of fired up about what i've
been doing
and i put that passion into what i'm
doing at microsoft so
it's kind of like a um
one thing affects the other thing yeah
yeah you know what it's like man you're
creative right yes when you when you're
being creative
it it affects your mind and your spirit
and so i think
whatever then you work whatever then
you're doing
next um gets the positive effect of that
i think
yeah 100 because uh i guess i was
thinking like when microsoft brought you
on the team
they look at the vast volume of work
you've done and i just wonder like
what are they thinking irony is though
mate honestly sorry to cut you off
no one no one really knows apart from
about 10 people in my studio
they haven't got a clue what we're
talking about now really
uh-huh i'm not that they should but like
it's just they just
they just don't have a clue so is that
is that a reflection of where culture is
going today like we've lost
sense of history and what's come before
and we're just in the now
uh yeah maybe maybe it's to deal with
the fact that i don't
put my name and face to everything that
could be a two
it could be that you don't think i'm
that guy from uh you know the
the other the actor chris yeah terminate
you probably think it's him
he's like an actor and he's a
typographer which is fine by me
and you kill type i mean no i'm just all
right
chris i know you have to run so i want
to thank you for coming on the show
thanks for sharing your process and your
knowledge guys definitely check out
chris
here's his information even though the
site is pre-baited or whatever
it's just not even ready for prime time
but yeah if you want it i wouldn't get
it
because it's not okay don't go to the
site go to the instagram account
instagram's got a lot of what's going to
be there anyways yeah and it's a
it's a beautiful inspirational thing i
look at it every day and you can see me
liking his uh post
almost every single time so thank you
yes it's at ashworth chris check it out
learn from your elders learn from the
masters guys
thank you very much for coming on the
show don't forget to like comment and
subscribe to this episode
heartfelt thank you to all our
sustaining members and the donuts you
guys know who you are
it's time for us to get out here thank
you very much chris thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
where's that screen aaron